chad
thank you i'm loving this so am i oh why
haven't we met sooner
i don't understand question that's the
question where you've been in canada all
this time in montreal canada and
montreal so you must speak french i do
fluently yes you have to it's a must do
you speak any languages
of french
you know
not too much of this and that do you
speak other languages i do italian and
spanish
but it's not about me it's about you why
the language it's a little involved
do languages
everything turns me on i'm very easily
stimulated believe you me
i apologize i'm uh
believable you me i think it's the heat
that's what it is that must be it it
says it's getting to us yeah okay um
revisiting this role after 20 years
what's happened to your character in the
last 20 years that's a good question so
uh if you followed if you were a
fan of the first one you remember what
happened i was a cable guy
ride my bicycle and uh
but i loved the environment
i loved the planet you know and i loved
people i had a very deep feeling for
people and and animals you know i don't
know if it came out in the first one but
i think i loved uh uh and had a feeling
of spiritual parody
is that the word i want with all the
living things on this earth and i felt
very
graced to be here and so you know and to
contribute to be able to contribute
that's what i was doing that whether you
knew it or not that's what i was doing
there and i was a romantic too you know
okay i had that you know uh i had
my woman you know uh and my wife but uh
but so so i found myself as remember in
the in the right place the right time to
to
help contribute and save the planet yeah
uh you know with this attack since then
they put me in charge of
uh since i seem to be a person of such
bravery and ingenuity uh they put me in
charge of i'm not i i've been the
director of the esd the earth space
defense so i work uh it's my privilege
to work with people
across all borders which have really
become less relevant now that we know
we're a family on a little tiny planet
in a
beautiful magical mysterious infinitely
lovely
universe uh um
what was i saying
so what are we it's my job to to to work
with them across the board and to and to
figure out how to how to help us if we
ever uh get into a situation like that
again so i've been working hard why are
you back again what made you want to
come back again oh me jeff goldblum yeah
well that's a good idea i like well
they wrote a good script they had some
good ideas wait till you see i can't
give them all the way but they had a
good eye many good ideas about what
happened and you'll see in the course of
this story
uh you know ways you know things that we
find out
that allow us to see what happened 20
years ago in a new light oh that's a
great team isn't that it's nice my
character is especially because i'm
trying as you can imagine figure things
out feel things out i'm an intuitive and
a passionate a person of gizzard and
tummy but i'm also a big big thinker and
a thinker out of the box and a creative
thinker so i so things happen don't go
yet don't chase her off yet
there are things that i can stay here
all day too me too anyway things happen
that make me go oh
i didn't understand about this and that
and this and that and now i understand
in a very big way about our place in the
universe and where this little story
about that happened 20 years ago fits in
to what's happening now and what might
fit into the rest of our lives here
wow bravo i like it i like